[Music]
we have a couple of questions but I sort
of tried I'd like to start with the some
of the points a few of our presenters
alluded to particularly about sample
custody and how quickly to get the
sample from the collection point to the
analysis and what does that if how does
that how important is this to the sample
eternity I mean if you'd like to get
started you know it definitely is
something to keep in mind I guess that
goes back to protocol you know some of
that just you know knowing that there is
probably gonna be some effect as you
maybe hold it or not but if you use it
consistently that's gonna help you out I
[Music]
banish to see what Carl in my cap you
know their market they might have some
Carl you well to acknowledge that when
you pull that manure sample out from the
rest of the manure you change it fireman
so it's going to start changing a little
different than the manure and the pond
is changing so that that's a concern but
I guess from my perspective I'm just
like my last slide where I had you know
that perfect sampling is not it's a
perfect sampling is unachievable but
good sampling is the process of getting
better over time so you know that's I
guess that's where I would put my focus
on is doing the best we can and
acknowledge there may be some
imperfections that are open for
improvements in the future so you know
go Roarke yeah I'll just I would just
add that that preference is is to get
that at least refrigerated as soon as
possible
don't leave it laying on the dash to
pick up for a week and then here we do
most of the samples come into the extend
in office where they're put into a
refrigerator transported to the lab once
a week and up here in Raleigh so so yeah
certainly it would be nice to put them
on on Ison or in it at least in the
cooler out of this direct sunlight until
you can get them refrigerated
yeah well the follow up on that is it's
recommended in Arkansas part of your
county office first as they wind you
when do you expect to be sipping a
mailing something out so you may want to
keep it refrigerator at home for a day
before you get it to any office and and
they'll they'll actually mail it out we
don't we don't have transportation for
texting mail to the center to the lab
let's be sure and label it appropriately
yes in your home refrigerator have a
specialized refrigerator and it having
my comment about when you fill the
bottles you pull them up 1/2 to 3/4 full
for I have 500 mil bottles of what we
use because you want to leave some room
for a good gas expansion you don't want
the tops to blow out and the post office
so there is one of the points that and
one of the questions raised is the
statistical analysis or sort of an idea
so variability in all of our
presentations today that variability is
the name of the game
so you're sampling you're trying to add
as many samples as you can to the
variability - so the good question
specifically what are the typical
statistical methods that you're relying
on in order to either analyze that
variability or to reduce that
variability in general so I kind of like
to start that a little bit so some of
the it's a personal experience some
people sampling has to do with just
increasing the number of samples and
seeing how that changes to me
essentially so that sort of almost like
a simulation where you're adding more
you're seeing how you are shifting the
mean typically this is how we reach the
to the rules of thumbs that we typically
have 8 to 10 samples and it varies
species to species but
I'm wondering any of the presenters if
they'd like to kind of contribute or
comment on this particular aspect of
mineral sampling well I'll just say from
a lagoon liquid standpoint the their the
the top water is relatively well mixed
and so it's not difficult for us to get
a representative sample simply by
walking around the lagoon and taking
grab samples but we also we're using
that same liquid that's being pumped
back to the barns to flush the barns so
most of our producers simply collect a
sample from the pipe as they're pumping
water back to the pits and that's and
plus there they are sampling relatively
frequently so they have a long-term data
set of lagoon analysis and it really
doesn't change significantly there is
some seasonal variabilities but it's not
a tremendous amount and the way the
records are done for their land
application it's essentially a checkbook
method that so they've got the fields
how much will they pump and then how
much the analysis for that so at the end
of the day when they entered all that
information in it comes out with a total
plant available nitrogen that's been
applied applied to that field now how I
would agree with mark that the top water
is fairly uniform and where I have my
concerns from a sampling of a holding
pond is where is the solids deposition
pattern because as the manure is
discharged into the pond from the pipe
there's a tendency to be right at the
end of the pipe there's kind of a clean
area where the flow of water flushes the
manure or solids away but then you start
getting a solids deposition in that area
and it's kind of a sweep then you move
farther away from the pond you'll have
the deposition will fall off and the
silence level will decrease of course
the whole ballgame changes the next time
they come in and they pump out or they
agitate so that's part of the sampling
process when you go around the
and why I like to use a clear PVC pipe
is that gives me an opportunity to
visually see that solid step and also
you can tell a lot just by the
resistance to insertion with the probe
as you go in and one time that I've
sampled pretty regularly I make them I
have the advantage of their wonder kind
of dock kind of out in it so it gave me
an opportunity to walk out the end of
the dock carefully yeah get the samples
from there and that actually happened to
be towards the end of where they had a
solid accumulation typically that's one
of the nice things that with that the
survey the remote control boats and and
sonar in that picture that I showed if
you can see that where that sludge is
and where you need to be guide that
sampling yeah from a historical or time
trends so to speak and Carl's slide kind
of we had a question on this point but
also one of the slides you presented on
accumulated data between oh five and
2010 from Allah and I'd like to kind of
open that question to our panel here and
in terms of your observation so
anecdotally some of the values are
changing diet changes in genetics so
changes in the manual nutrient values
that you are seeing or observing or sort
of key takeaways on that front compared
to the typical book value that we have
established the the anecdotal on the
poultry side is yeah there's changes
over time because our poultry industry
has gone from rebuilding the house
completely every after every flock to
you may not read bed the house
completely if you know it may happen
every third year so just just the carbon
editions in extraction and litter
management has changed manure over time
on the liquids
I've had several occasions where I would
have an integrator a producer raising
for an integrator who
come names at Carl explain why my manure
used to be this way and now it's like
Hamlin oatmeal in this Daleks were the
only thing we configure is it was a diet
change of course the diet changes are
driven by the least-cost rations as well
as nutrient balance so Mort and I don't
have a lot of data to support it but
certainly anecdotally talking with folks
in the swine industry the feed rations
have changed and now as folks are
starting to clean out legumes we are
seeing there indications that that's
true and if you if you just start
stripping away layers you can see higher
concentrations of phosphorus zinc and
copper in the in that sludge so yes I
think there's evidence of that I think
we need to do a better job of
quantifying that and my mood and I've
talked about how do we do that and
setting up some sampling plugins sludge
sampling protocols to kind of try and
address that yeah I think the key
take-home wound justice discussion is to
just read the variability means you
really need to be developing a farm
specific database of what your sample of
what you're applying and really give
some thought in terms of what what are
you doing and why are you doing it and
what's the best way to do it well I
would say that also reinforces some
earlier discussion about sampling
beforehand because we've have had some
instances where folks a dredge sludge
put it out based on what they thought it
was going to be and based on their
initial sample turns out what they
actually dredge was different than that
and they've over applied both phosphorus
and copper zinc and a few few instances
and to the point that some folks are
reluctant very reluctant to accept
sludge application now on fields
well I'd like to thank our presenters
for this really informative material on
your sampling
[Music]